we start tonight with an important
message from the President of the United
States take a look so it's 15 days from
yesterday we'll see what happens after
that if we do this right our country and
the world frankly but our country can be
rolling again pretty quickly pretty
quickly we have to fight that invisible
enemy that I guess unknown but we're
getting to know it a lot better
invisible enemy the president's right as
we speak this country the entire world
is in a fight against that enemy and now
major financial help is on the way the
White House actively working on an
aggressive almost trillion dollar
stimulus package including a payroll tax
cut money for small businesses emergency
assistance to major industries that are
directly impacted by this virus that
would mean yeah the airline industry
cruise industry Treasury secretary and
minuchin said today that the president
wants Americans to receive checks within
two weeks
look we're Americans we are going to
help out our fellow Americans this
country rebuilt Europe after World War
two we saved an entire world numerous
times from evil and tyranny we did it
again and again we paid that price we
must help our fellow Americans like post
9/11 Industries directly impacted they
will rightly get the help they deserve
American workers they've got to get the
help they deserve we help countries
every day and night in every single time
we help the world small businesses
they've got to get the help they deserve
and need and hopefully something
nonpartisan I have a huge caveat on this
all of you swamp creatures pay attention
we won't find the money that's who we
are
but Washington all of you
Republicans and Democrats stop with the
pork barrel misuse of our tax dollars if
you remember a Congress this is not
about your special interest projects
this money every penny of this money
needs to go to American workers American
businesses directly impacted by the
virus that's it that's what this bill
should be not
more nothing less it's got to be managed
wisely so people who need the assistance
get the assistance and get it as quickly
as possible
not power-hungry politicians who build
their power base by creating dependency
that want to spend it on issues that
have nothing coronavirus related to do
with this this is a crucial moment
because even now the US military is
confronting coronavirus that threat
head-on and breaking tonight the
Department of Defense they are now
deploying five million and ninety five
mass to healthcare professionals
nationwide that's great news why well
we've got to protect health care workers
that throw themselves in front of this
virus and every other illness and
disease every single day they've got to
be protected Department of Defense is
also releasing an additional 2,000
ventilators in case civilians need them
in preparation for a worst-case scenario
military hospital ships they are now
being prepared for possible deployment
to help overcrowding in hospitals plus
the department of defense's opening 14
new coronavirus certified testing labs
the National Guard now assisting states
with logistics and medical support
it's an all-hands-on-deck situation by
the way states governors municipalities
mayors you got to do your job - thanks
to some very decisive early action by
the president we're now in a position to
beat this disease mitigate the impact of
the president's temporary travel ban
every day we now see how critical this
was at a critical time very successful
slowing the spread of that disease that
now the European Union is replicating
the band within their own borders it's a
little late for them the first case in
this country was January 21st first
known case the travel ban was put in
place ten days later on January 31st
nobody's ever acted that quickly to stop
the spread of a pandemic
by the way can the media find one good
thing to say about Trump we'll get to
that later in the show now on the very
same day Oh
quid pro quo dr. Joe said it was
fear-mongering in Zita xenophobic and
hysterical that one decision that travel
ban followed by the quarantine prevented
this pandemic
from being exponentially worse meaning
thousands and thousands of more
Americans would have contracted this
disease and it would have been
dramatically more difficult to contain
and mitigate and meanwhile the
president's groundbreaking
public-private partnership is resulting
in expedited testing for Americans they
now have their drive-through testing
centers that's a good thing the last
place you really want to be right now if
you don't have to be there is a hospital
why because we need beds for those that
really need it number one number two
it's a petri dish you don't want to be
there and with red tape / scientists
medical researchers our doctors are now
rapidly developing not only treatments
but hopefully a vaccine this
unprecedented cooperation between the
government private industry this will
now forever change the way this country
and the world will deal with future
pandemics and crises just like the
travel ban unfortunately tonight a bad
news to report why Philly and their
Police Department there's doing this I
don't know they're placing an indefinite
pause on arrests for certain nonviolent
crimes crimes are still pursuant to a
warrant served at a later date but the
new policy is really bad and a bad idea
that will license people to commit
crimes and sometimes major cases the
city of Philadelphia must continue to
enforce the law especially during times
of uncertainty all you or you will have
war law breaking you will say go ahead
you're fine that's not good for the
people of Philadelphia we'll keep you
posted also let's get to some important
facts and information again without fear
tonight is expected the number of
confirmed coronavirus cases in the u.s.
that is rising there are now more than
6,000 confirmed cases in the United
States we've been telling you this is
happening sadly over now a hundred
deaths in the u.s. now those numbers as
I've been saying will likely rise
seemingly and dramatically in the next
days and weeks the hope is that if we
follow the president the vice president
the task force 15 day recommendation we
will mitigate the spread of this virus
so that's why it's important and listen
up because it's more important than ever
to heed the guidance of this task force
and the president what they're calling
on all of us to do for the health and
safety and security especially
for older Americans those with
compromised immune systems underlying
health conditions take the following
crucial precautions over the next couple
of weeks do it why because we love our
grandmothers our grandfathers our older
moms and dads they're the most
vulnerable they're the most at risk if
you feel sick stay home the kids feel
sick keep them at home anyone near your
house test positive for coronavirus keep
the entire household at home if you're
an elderly person or someone with these
underlying medical conditions or you
have a compromised immune system or
autoimmune disease or you went through
chemotherapy and radiation you need to
stay away from other people on your own
if possible work from home avoid
discretionary travel avoid big social
gatherings avoid nursing homes avoid
large group settings in other words for
the next two weeks you can sit on a sofa
you can stay at home we hope you'll stay
with us here in Fox News but we're
trying to get you the information that
will keep your family safe but by simply
doing nothing we can all save lives we
can flatten the curve of the disease we
can get back to normal we will
eventually great winston churchill can't
believe in the middle of the bombing of
britain every single day walk among the
people of Great Britain you know what is
it blood toil tears and sweat vowed to
wage war by sea land and air victory
that was the goal we will be victorious
here our president challenge requires a
little more than social distancing for
the majority of our population can all
do our part like I said an
all-hands-on-deck situation but for many
most the vast majority dr. pouchy told
me on my radio show again today know if
you're young healthy and you don't have
a compromised immune system you might if
you contracted the virus you may have no
symptoms you may have mild symptoms you
may get a full-on flu it's passing it on
to those people that would be at risk
that is the fear this country will be
fine in the end we have the best doctors
hospitals scientists medical researchers
military the greatest economy in the
world has ever seen and we have an
abundance of food an abundance of
natural resources a robust hard-working
intelligent population oh the president
spoke with America's big grocery chains
they are filling those
you know don't run in for toilet paper
and extra paper towels why do people go
for that first I don't get it because
they're going to be filling the shelves
everywhere across the country and that
is also in the works tonight we'll pull
together we'll defeat this invisible
enemy lawmakers in Washington you need
to put aside the BS politics these
Americans need help don't waste our
money don't waste it
it's important to our hardworking
Americans impact it's important to
important industries to this economy
give it to the people that deserve it
and only the people that deserve it in
the right way and set the economy up for
quick growth and this is all done before
we get to our guests I have one more
important message make no mistake the
dictatorship of China is this is where
the pandemic started I'm not saying
they're responsible for the pandemic
they are responsible for being
irresponsible trying to hide it
misinforming the rest of the world
rather than inviting the world to offer
their help and assistance to them now
during that critical those critical
early stages China's so-called leaders
they tried to cover everything up
instead of alerting the world community
they silenced the doctors working on the
frontlines many themselves now
contracted the virus some have even died
China's government spreading fake
information propaganda and lies they are
falsely even blaming the US military for
the disease I was glad the president
pushed back hard against them today for
that now as part of their massive
cover-up they're kicking out all members
of the media from the New York Times
Wall Street Journal Washington Post okay
you all should be ashamed of yourselves
in China because it's your reckless
actions that have led to thousands of
deaths not only in your own country but
around the world we would have gladly
helped you you should have asked for the
help the rest of the world would have
gladly helped you millions more are now
suffering because of your brutal
dictatorship and you're a lack of
accountability you ultimately need to
take responsibility for all of that
joining us now with the latest facts
without fear so you will be informed
without hype and hysteria